the US Coast Guard could have its hands
full as Irma makes its way through
Florida the guard 7th district is
responsible for a wide area it includes
Florida Georgia South Carolina and
Puerto Rico rear admiral Peter Brown is
the commander of the seventh district
and he joins us now on the phone from
Orlando good morning Admiral Brown good
morning and thank you for this
opportunity to explain how your United
States first part is getting ready for
the impacts of hurricane so tell me what
your priorities are well our top
priority is always the safety of human
life so we are already protecting and
positioning Coast Guard responders and
Coast Guard assets our life-saving
helicopters folks and Coast Guard
cutters from across the country those
resources would be in position just
outside the state of Florida in Alabama
in Georgia South Carolina and North
Carolina to be ready to respond as
quickly as we can to those top two
priorities protecting human life is
priority number one and our second
priority will be reopening and restoring
the ports especially those that are most
critical to the fuel supply of Florida
and those at Fort Lauderdale well we
certainly saw Herculean efforts by the
Coast Guard in Harvey a couple of weeks
ago what exactly you expected to be
dealing with today paint a picture for
us please Admiral well every storm is
different both in the mix of the key
threats of the storm in this case as
many of the forecasters have described
the key threat from Hurricane karma is
the life-threatening storm surge that's
a little different from the rain event
that hurricane Harvey was but those same
assets those same helicopters those same
flood boats those same people that
responded to Harvey have repositioned to
be ready to respond to hurricane Irma so
whether the primary need is for certain
rescue efforts in the Florida Keys and
the West Coast of Florida or exploring
the ports of Port Everglades in Miami
and forth an apple will be ready what
types of resources has the Coast Guard
deployed the Coast Guard has made every
operational resource of our service
available we are putting resources from
this far away in some cases Cape Cod
Massachusetts Seattle Washington and
even people from Alaska and Hawaii to be
ready to respond to this storm one of
our challenges with this particular
storm hurricane Irma is its sheer size
intensity and attract that encompasses
and threatens the entire state of
Florida
needs a response will be hampered it'll
be slowed down because there's just so
much of Florida to travel through or fly
through to get to the places where we'll
be needed most it is said that it is sad
that the storm no I think we're
preparing what you said about the size
of this storm it is said that it is 420
miles wide than the width of the state
of Florida and our key operational bases
on air stations in Miami and Clearwater
and our cutter home ports of Miami and
Key West and st. Pete are small boat
stations throughout the state they are
all in the impact zones and they're
likely to be damaged in some ways and so
we have to restore those bases to
operational capability to at the same
time that we're performing life-saving
search and rescue operations well we
hear how big it is can you give us a
sense of the number of resources you're
employing to take care of it
I don't have specific numbers available
for you but I can tell you that every
operational resource that's available at
east coast of the United States is made
available to me to respond for this
storm as soon as we identify precisely
where those key needs are going to be
all right Rear Admiral Peter Brown we
thank you very much for taking the time
to join us this morning we like the
Coast Guard - thank you sir